I was a little worried at first that
being pro-sex robot might be an
irresponsible take what if I'm condoning
something weird what kind of people buy
these things are they psychos perverse
so I did want to do my research so what
I did was I logged on to a forum
secretly of the men that owned the most
current version of the sex robots and I
monitored their conversations for two
months
that's the kind of time I have
and look I thought they were going to be
creeps Psychopaths I don't know what to
tell you they're very lovely men they're
lovely they adore their dolls they marry
their dolls that is happening I know it
sounds crazy but it is now my dream in
life to go to a sex robot wedding that's
all I want
mostly because I'm dying to see what a
wedding would look like if it was solely
planned by a man
creative
chips she's just gonna come out in like
a dolphin's Jersey like Air Jordans
he's dragging her down the aisle like
weekend at Bernie he's like oh
like who sits in the bride section is it
the UPS guy that delivered her I just I
have a lot of questions
after seeing these guys talk about how
much they love their dolls and share
information about taking care of them
it's really hard when someone wants to
argue with me about it when someone says
well what if these men start treating
human women the way they treat their
dolls I got news for you they treat
their dolls fucking great I actually
argue these are the only men that know
how hard it is to be a woman they're on
the message boards they're like can you
believe mascara is 18. they get it we
want this to catch on if guys start
buying makeup the price will go down if
the guys start buying eye shadow it's
gonna be like two dollars at Home Depot
so let's get this show on the roads
this is what it has to come to
I don't know I did a total 180 I thought
they were gonna be weirdos but now I'll
tell you if I was single I would date a
doll guy I'm gonna say they have the
skills I need they can do eyebrows they
can do women's Nails okay they can fully
dress their doll while she's lying down
that's what I needed a man
a man who can fully change my clothes
while I'm sleeping that is a Time Saver
alarm goes off about the fucking door in
my procs and mini skirt hashtag girlboss
so interesting I'm on these boards and I
did come across something that I do not
condone some of the guys were trying to
design and 3D print their own robot at
home no no you guys cannot design your
own female body that would be a disaster
they would all just have like nine boobs
across their chest the belly button
would be a bottle opener their face
would just be Joe Rogan it's a bad idea
it's a copyright issue
I did get final confirmation that the
robots are not going to replace Us in
kind of a weird way so when guys order a
robot they post photos online of the
robot being built in the factory right
it's weird-ass photo so I'm looking and
I'm looking in the background trying to
like find Clues and you know and I see
that women are actually building the
faces of the Dolls interesting put a pin
in that we're gonna Circle back
because then I saw a thread where guys
were complaining about the struggles
they were having in their doll
relationships one of the threads was
titled does anyone else struggle with
when receiving oral from their doll
her eyes pop out
then I thought about the women making
the dolls these bitches have our backs
[Applause]